les camionneurs brésiliens sont pour
l'instant les sols à protester contre la
défaite de leurs candidat le président
Jaïr bolsonaro dès le résultat de
l'élection ils ont bloqué les routes de
la plupart des États du pays et en
particulier l'axe crucial Rio de Janeiro
sympa holo sans prenant à l'occasion aux
automobilistes partisans du vainqueur
Lula leur syndicat la police négocie une
solution
mais la nuit dernière au palais
présidentiel d'alvorada brésilia aucune
réaction aucun mot du président Jaïr
bolsonaro après le résultat
et au matin il n'est pas allé rencontrer
ses partisans son petit cercle comme il
le fait tous les jours
à barade et tijuka l'entrée des
résidences de Bara ou demeure jaillir
bolsonaro à Rio et des herbes
une journaliste plus de partisans
Papito qui hier encore faisait des
affaires avec le nom de Jaïr bolsonaro
ne sait pas présenté au travail ces
objets vont passer au rayon des
souvenirs il va devoir changer de
vocation
seul vestige de la propagande ce loup la
gonflable en costume de repris de
justice quelques autocollants politiques
que le service de la voirie à négligée
dans son grand nettoyage l'histoire
change de direction
les partisans du président sortant se
lamentaient de la défaite en priant pour
un miracle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
contraste avec ses partisans de Lula du
quartier branché de Flamengo à Rio
qui se réjouissait sans retenue du
départ d'un président détesté
[Applaudissements]
ils sont jeunes sympathiques et joyeux
derrière un président de 77 ans
fondateur du vieux parti des
travailleurs un revenant Louis Ignacio
Lula da Silva de présidents un cancer le
scandale de corruption du siècle 18 mois
de prison et qui célèbre une journée
historique
ou la majorité des Brésiliens ont dit
qu'il voulait plus et n'ont pas moins de
démocratie
mais il aura fort à faire l'extrême
droite bolsonariste la droite
conservatrice et religieuse évangélique
seront puissants au Congrès et chez les
gouverneurs des états c'est les plus
difficiles parce que la radicalisation
du point de vue de vision de
possibilités sur la société a pour la
première fois mise en place une vision
extrême qui a l'intention de détruire
les fondements de la démocratie Ricardo
Enrique a déjà travaillé pour lui il
croit que Lula est capable d'y arriver
très difficile mais là a une vertu qui
est la capacité
d'entendre ce que les gens
ont besoin ils je crois c'est pas sûr
qu'il va arriver à faire là à faire ça
mais je crois qu'il a tout les éléments
sont capables de produire une grande
concertation nationale la transition
jusqu'au 1er janvier sera difficile nous
là on a donné la charge à son vieil
adversaire de centre droit Géraldo
alcmin qui sera sans vice-président une
figure rassurante on dit à Brasilia que
Jahr bolsonaro s'est réuni avec ses
ministres et ses conseillers qui lui
recommande de ne pas contester de
reconnaître la victoire de Lula va-t-il
le faire et comment il doit prendre la
parole au plus tard demain Jean-Michel
Leprince Radio-Canada Rio de Janeiro